Everyone knows the lengths to which Marvel
Studios and Avengers: Endgame directors Joe
and Anthony Russo have gone to prevent any
spoilerific leaks from flooding the internet.
There's the now-standard sneaky editing of
trailers to include and exclude certain footage,
and reports of the Brothers Russo crafting
purposefully confusing days on set — but
now we're learning another technique the Endgame
team implemented to protect the film and keep
everyone in the dark until the movie's premiere.
Bruce Banner actor Mark Ruffalo recently revealed
that he shot five different endings for Avengers:
Endgame — and for a pretty hilarious reason.
Chatting with E! News alongside his co-stars
Chris Evans and Karen Gillan Ruffalo admitted
that he has absolutely no idea how Endgame
truly ends, or what really happens in the
movie… because he never got a complete script.
"I don't know what's gonna happen.
I shot, like, five different endings to this
movie.
I didn't even get a whole script to this movie.
And I don't know why."
He added that the version of the Endgame script
he did receive, quote, "had dummy scenes in
it," one of which included Evans' Captain
America tying the knot.
Mark's a real liability.
"He gets married in this!"
They have to throw Mark off the scent."
Flabbergasted, Ruffalo asked Evans why Marvel's
braintrust would knowingly steer him in the
wrong direction.
"You have earned no trust in the Marvel universe.
You, like, leak like a bodily function."
"Like I need a diaper?"
It turns out that the majority of the Endgame
cast was given the same treatment as Ruffalo:
they shot the film with incomplete scripts.
Another member of the Endgame crew that wasn't
entrusted with the full story?
The notorious spoiler-spiller Tom Holland,
who knows even less about what goes down in
Endgame than Ruffalo.
The Hulk star at least had mock-up scenes
to read and fake endings to film, but Holland
wasn't awarded such a luxury.
Director Joe Russo previously explained that
the Spider-Man actor only had access to his
lines and nothing else — for the very same
reason Ruffalo was kept uninformed and made
to shoot a bunch of different conclusions.
He said at a fan event for the film in India,
"Tom Holland does not get the script.
Tom Holland gets his lines and that's it.
He doesn't even know who he's acting opposite
of … we use, like, very vague terms to describe
to him what is happening in the scene, because
he has a very difficult time keeping his mouth
shut."
In defense of Marvel and the Russo brothers'
tactics, it's true that Ruffalo hasn't exactly
been the best gatekeeper of the studio's secrets,
having accidentally let slip information that
was meant to be guarded as if his life depended
on it.
In the past, Ruffalo unintentionally live-streamed
to his Instagram followers the first 20 minutes
of audio from Thor: Ragnarok during the film's
Los Angeles world premiere back in 2017.
And who can forget the time Ruffalo completely
spoiled the ending of Avengers: Infinity War
during an interview with ABC's Good Morning
America?
“Wait til you see this next one.
Everybody dies."
"Dude!
Dude…
“Not everybody"
Make no mistake about it: Marvel is serious
about shielding secrets — now more so than
ever.
As the film approaches its April 26 launch
date, the studio is going to crack down on
potential spoiler-sharers.
So remember, kids, keep those lips buttoned
until everyone has a chance to see Endgame...or
else face the wrath of Thanos.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.